okay so obviously the situation in terms
of covet is
i'm quite dire and we've saw images this
week which we never want to see repeated
again
particularly around the fact that we've
had people being treated out the back of
ambulances at anthem hospital it's very
clear from um the cases the positive
cases that we're seeing every day
that an urgent intervention was required
so the executive has had
detailed discussion around and what that
needed to be
around the duration of that and the
specifics of all of that
so what has been decided today is that
there is going to be a six week
lockdown and that begins on the 26th of
december
there will also be so that will stay in
place for as i said for a period of six
weeks but there will be an inbuilt
review after
four weeks um in addition to that
there will also be a week where there'll
be even more additional restrictions to
what will be
um remaining over the course of the six
week period and i'll talk a bit more
about those in a second for those that
have chosen to form
a family bubble for a small time over
the the christmas period that that will
still be facilitated so that's still
allowed to go ahead i think that
just in terms of what will be closed
over the six-week period
we'll have the closure of hospitality in
its entirety apart from takeaway
their off licenses will close at 8
o'clock all non-essential retail will be
closed
and car washes will be closed dog
agreement will be opened hotels will be
opened until the 28th to accommodate the
christmas
um situation there will also be
financial supports put in place
so the current measures which we've had
over previous and restrictions will be
rolled over
to support businesses through this very
challenging time
the additional week of restrictions that
will begin on the 26th
will mean that in that week there will
be no sporting
activity at all so um things that have
been planned will not be able to go
ahead and obviously that's um would be
very disappointing for those people that
are organizing those events but it's a
necessary
um intervention also in that wake
um all businesses that are allowed to
open so your
essential shops for example will all be
asked to close at eight o'clock
so no businesses will be opened after
eight o'clock
so i think that this is uh it'll be
disappointing to many i think a lot of
people also would have expected it
and it's very clear that we needed an
urgent intervention um i think this is
the right decision by the executive
albeit i accept it'll be challenging for
many many people
we tried to get a balance in all of
these things but um it's clear that we
needed a longer and for
intervention and i believe that's what's
been arrived at this evening and that's
been a collective
position from the executive that has
been arrived at this event